what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a video by
mike rashad talking about how he
disrespects the red pill
after attending a fresh and fit podcast
i noticed that a lot of you guys were
watching this video so i wanted to react
to it live before i start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification
bell um as you guys know i'm trying to
hit 20 000 subscribers so
each and every one of you helps me hit
that goal
all right i'm ready to go what up
youtube i am yours
mediocre tutorials and reviews back in
here
with one more video
guys you're looking at the title of the
video you're looking at the thumbnail
you already know what time it is it is
time to get active
shout out to mike rashid
all right he's an actor slash fitness
enthusiast over a million subscribers on
his youtube channel he was recently at
the fresh and fit
podcast shout out to those brothers
and came under a bit of scrutiny because
of his mindset in his
ideologies
he recently was streaming believe he
streamed
and he was talking about his thoughts of
not only his appearance on the show but
this whole red pill and blue pill
ish and what women
actually prefer i thought it'd be
interesting conversation for us to
review and go
over without further ado so the topic
today
is do you know red pill blue pill
um it's a reason for that you know
uh basically um when i was in miami
shout out to freshman fit podcast good
dudes
i had a lot of fun on their podcast uh
we um discussed a lot of things
a lot of things about women came up and
um
there was a lot of uh discussion
a lot of comments with guys calling me
blue pill blue pill
he's blue pill calling you blue yeah
they were like some of their
fans they were saying some of them were
saying oh he's purple
he's blue he's purple i'm like what the
[ __ ] is all of this
so i went and looked it up all right
because i was thinking is this from the
matrix like what are they talking about
right
i don't really subscribe to i don't put
myself in any
particular box at all and so the idea
from the matrix was
if you take the blue pill you remain in
a life
of tranquility and and
unawareness if you will and if you take
the red pill
you go down the rabbit hole and you get
to learn what's really going on
and that will forever change you so
these people have clearly taken that
idea
and they're doing something else with it
so we need help to understand what that
is
all right let me read the official from
uh
our favorite wikipedia you know what's
um i always find it really interesting
to see people kind of um
without really understanding the space
try to like
understand it and what's interesting
about the way that he described that is
is that
the blue pill you live in tranquility
but what we find out often
is that if you remain completely blue
pill
you don't often live in tranquility you
know
you don't soon or later
reality strikes you and up ends you the
carpet gets ripped right from under
yeah i i see what he said it's funny
because i'm i'm that person right that's
trying to understand the space
um but it's interesting because
the red pill community just seems to
think like this is how the world works
this is how it is
there are not many exceptions this is
how the majority of the world
works and i don't think i'm 100 bought
into that because i don't think most
people are watching these videos or
thinking about this kind of stuff
um so i don't know it's hard it's hard
because i see
some like things that i would say ring
true but i also hear other stuff that's
like
i don't know
i know the red pill is gonna hate that
answer is too broad
because you're exposed to true nature
let's keep going let's see here red hill
i love
i love wikipedia okay
red pill and blue pill the term
red pill and blue pill refer to a choice
between the willingness to learn
a potentially unsettling or
life-changing truth
by taking the poll i'm sorry the red
pill
or remaining in contended ignorance with
the blue pill
the term refers to yada yada the matrix
from 99.
so now it doesn't seem like that's what
people are used
that's how people are using it so let's
go to what what people are really
talking about and i guess it comes from
reddit
right and there was a a thing called
where to go the red reddit red pill
let me see seem to have lost that page
let me find it
all right what is red pill about red
pill is a collection of ideas
and comp encompassed by what is
subscriber
what its subscribers refer to as the
manosphere
all right a number of loosely associated
blogs that focus on masculinity
and personal philosophy for men at the
surface
at the surface level there is nothing
terribly contentious about this
but if you click around one or two
layers deeper you'll find plenty of
examples
why chatter from this gallery regularly
turn
turn says so sean i'm asking you this i
want to find this other article that i
seen earlier
when you hear red pill blue pill have
you heard that term
not as it relates to the battle of
the genders or like the masculinity
under attack war
i haven't heard it for that until you
brought it up the other day right
i have of course heard it in
relationship to the life of
ignorance and tranquility versus the
life of discovery and challenging
notions
correct correct and for folks that don't
know either uh
the whole matrix red pill blue pill
stuff is using a lot of other
things outside of what we talk about
over here right politics use it that's
actually the first place that i ever saw
it outside of the matrix
was politics politics they say are you
red pill you blue pill like do you
really
want to understand the machine i've
never heard that
in politics engine do you really want to
understand what's behind the curtains i
mean that that that's the first place
that i heard it so having it used from a
dating relationship perspective uh was
new to me a couple of years ago and then
after i
was watching it i was like oh yeah i've
known about this for a long time now so
uh let's continue all right so the
i haven't really heard it outside of the
matrix to be honest
um but let me find that uh that other
article
all right here it goes ready red bill
all right
so imagine wait wait in front of her all
right
the man who uses the internet handle
blah blah blah
all right as he tells it girls threw
themselves at us for a sip of our vodka
to sit with us to feel wanted
these girls had no intent on actually
getting with him okay
yeah duh like at a club all right
i think we're finding we're we're
peeling back layers right now
imagine a vert of the reverse i tried it
a table of girls i went over to the
girls on the other side of the club and
said hi
can i get a sip of your champagne can i
join you
what was the response [ __ ] off go away
who are you
why should we let you sit here with us i
wouldn't think that would
i mean i believe them that that's what
happened but like
when people are confident i see
things like work out for them more than
i see it not work out for them
said exactly the same to the woman that
came to us
so a group of single girls on the table
allowed some women to sit with them
rather than
an attractive male who they didn't know
who actually had a table himself
point is they tried failed and i tried
to go to a group of girls and i failed
yada yada yada so basically uh
red pill community is founded on a
general belief
this is like all right yeah it's
confusing it's found on a general belief
that women have
it better than men red pill is not
dating a vice bulletin
but rather a form for people men mostly
exploring an ideology that revolves amo
almost exclusively around gender those
who swallow the pill maintain that it's
men not women who have been socially
disenfranchised feminism
is considered a damaging ideology and
red pillars are quick to cite examples
that bolster their points
some going so far as to argue that
society is outright anti-male
red i i agree with that on some level
like it's hard because
with like feminism there's some things
that i do think were like helpful
for women but i can definitely see there
being like
anti-male rhetoric and negative effects
that like
came after pill followers have their own
politics language blah blah blah
let me let me just before he gets into
his comments i don't agree with that
with that summary and honestly this is
the problem
with when people will talk about red
pill which is why like on this channel
i'd never said well at least recently i
have not said
this is a red pill channel i have not
said that because
i lead with my own ideologies i think
that
because i don't 100 agree with content
creators that identify with red pill
like i i absolutely don't so uh i think
that it's
awkward for my image and what the things
that i talk about on this channel to say
these are red pill methods these are red
pill ideologies like nah like this just
comes
from up here but a lot of what i say uh
can be substantiated
by that framework and a lot of the
framework of red hill i agree with but
there's some things in there that i
absolutely don't
but when i think of red pill i think of
understanding
female nature now what do i add on to
that
i think that it's important to
understand your own nature
male nature as well and i think that the
the more that you can understand about
the people you live this earth with
the people that are in your lives at a
general level because
not all not all not all when you get
down to the specifics of course there's
going to be idiosyncrasies between each
human being that's going to make them a
little bit differently
but in general you have to understand
general truths
about female nature and male nature i
actually do think that
watching the red pill has had like me
understand why i've made like certain
decisions or why
um like
i don't know there's just certain things
that i didn't really realize like
why i felt that way like when they talk
about how women are just emotional and a
lot of times they're not arguing to find
like a solution they're just arguing to
argue like i think women get a lot more
like
frustrated than men with things and how
um like women pay more attention to like
the small details
just like stuff like that and if you do
not do that you will lessen
the likelihood of a successful
joyous and happy life but the thing is
is that
it is structured more so with
understanding female nature
because you love women as a heterosexual
male
you love women and in order to love
there's a degree of trust there
there's a degree of your heart that you
put within that so with that
they have the availability to rip your
heart to shreds
if you don't understand them you
understand that's what really i talk
about from this sector it's all in an
understanding of
yourself the opposite gender and how can
you get from point a
to point b living the most happiest life
possible and then at point z
looking back and saying i did everything
that i goddamn do to be the best human
being that i positively can
and i didn't suffer relentless losses
that killed my joy in
life this whole [ __ ] about women
having it better than men you know i
think like what i say before
from a dating perspective i think women
have it harder because
you ever play like a video game and is
you start off the the level
and there's like a time limit there's
like a time limit in that [ __ ]
and the extra added pressure that you
feel to complete that level i've
actually said this i think heart dating
is harder for women than men
because not only that you also have to
deal with like
um like people
pretending to like like you and stuff
like i don't think
men it's usually pretty obvious when a
girl doesn't like you you just don't
read the signs in my opinion level
successfully right before time runs out
that's what women are on right now
because that wall is realer than a
[ __ ]
dudes i think from a general life
perspective i agree with this i
agree with what he's saying we are not
validated
and our value was not predicated on
genetic [ __ ] we have to create ourselves
as men
we have to we have to create who we are
we have to
we need to be in tune with and learn our
masculinity and our manhood we have to
we have to do this
but women live a lot more passive lives
in fixing themselves getting therapy for
themselves
going to the gym for themselves in order
to
get the vying attention of a man that
they actually want live a lot more
passively within that
but it is what it is let's go on and see
his thoughts i agree with what he said
like
like as a guy at least you know that
even if you don't
dealt the best hand you can improve and
get better but like as a woman you only
know that it's gonna get worse
and that thought in the back your head
kind of blows i'm not gonna lie
let me just jump to the [ __ ] man like
how i feel about this
that last statement was was very telling
red pill followers have their own
politics no no back it up
uh red pillars are quick to cite
examples that
bolster their points some going so far
as to argue that society
is outright anti-male
anti-male so
to be anti-male but this is what i think
for society to be anti-male then 50
of society would have to like be dislike
be like anti-male and they're literally
males but
at the same time i do see like people
saying that men shouldn't have an
opinion on certain things and like
whatever
so um
yeah i don't know that's my thought that
would
infer that society is ran by women and
it's not
i don't think i'm wrong about this um
i don't i don't subscribe to that notion
i don't feel like society is
anti-male it's only male and female
right
but if it's ran by male i do see women
getting like favors and stuff
because these guys just like want to
sleep with them and i think that's
sometimes where
men get mad because they see them
getting like looked over for these girls
that are just hot
or good there's some other kind of
species or
gender that's that exists that's
stifling
um you know what men is about or
whatever in this country
we're less than 100 years in on the
ability of women
to contribute to the democracy
we're less than 100 years in on that so
basically women
so women were only able to vote less
than 100 years ago
less than 100 years ago that's crazy
so to say that it's an anti-male society
i think it's just it is it's coming from
a place of
of jealousy or or poor life experience
or whatever
but it's not accurate but you can't
overlook the fact that the court
system is stacked like for women that
men are overlooked for certain jobs
because they need to feel
fill a quota for women um and even like
when i was at my sales job like i would
always get special favors and special
help so i could see why they would think
that but i also
gosh i am not being decisive at all
today and what
what i'm saying but i don't know if you
guys understand like i could see both
sides
like there's a lot of fragility and
the mindset behind people who subscribe
to this right
men i don't now i've seen
i've been just paying attention since
this has been on my radar
and it seems like there's a commonality
there's
a common denominator amongst the people
who subscribe to
this red pill ideology i'm not saying
all
but i see a common thread talk about
that is somewhat of a
hatred or disdain towards women right
and and i also see like so you have this
guy
uncle kev kevin samuels right um
you know just real quick before it goes
into kevin samuels hatred and disdain
are very words matter those are very
different things
those are very different things but if
we could talk about um
how certain dudes do have hatred and do
have disdain
that exists within the red pill space
that absolutely is the truth
but i think what he's more so referring
to is this concept of red pill rage
which i've gone over ad nauseam on the
channel before even talking about
me overcoming my red pill rage when i
lived a life behind rose-colored
glasses and then i had the rug rip from
out of me
and the rage that i felt when
understanding like oh people are not
as truthful as me like
oh my gosh i had that same realization
when i hit a certain age like
i didn't realize that people lied and
like didn't tell the truth
i remember i was in high school and my
friend like said something and then
right after she's like yeah
i was just lying and i remember looking
at her being like
what what and it hit me like a ton of
bricks i'm just like wait a minute
people lie like that like i it just
it blew my mind it it absolutely blew my
mind
but that rage that i felt right
without understanding the benefits of
therapy at the time that rage that i
felt when i was just like wait a minute
how much of this has been a lie
throughout my life i felt
and i still think that it's necessary
for men to go through
now what i don't think is necessary is
to stay there
is to stay there but that rage creates
the burning platform
for change and i think that it's
necessary
so just being honest during that time
that i was red pill rage within my life
would i say that i had a disdain for
women
yes i absolutely did i absolutely did
and it came off in
very self-destructive ways
very self-destructive ways hatred no but
this name
absolutely how did it show itself i was
getting like
viscous emits from women that were in
relationships and
i knew that they were in relationships
but i just didn't care because
but see like women go through the same
thing
like i remember in college like being
shocked by how many people cheated on
their significant other because
i don't know i'm like a super loyal
person so i wouldn't i could not do that
with someone that like
i'm in love with and it would always
just like shock me
but yeah at some point you have to see
the world for how it is
kind of cause my disdain for them made
me want to
see if it was all a lie and once that
truth was confirmed to me because they
were doing these but like this is what
happens to girls too and that's why
i hate men or men are trash like the
same thing happens
to me i'm just looking at them with
disdain and disgust because i'm just
like
what part of the game is this you
understand me
after time after a while i was able to
get up out of that rage but that's a
whole other different type of a
conversation
but i think it's important to hit on
because there's a bunch of different
creators within the sector and the issue
is is that there's not a standardized
definition
we all take different pieces and parts
and then create our platform
some of which the words that we say show
a disdain for women
and some do not some is just hitting it
from a male point of view so then women
and men
confuse the information that we pour out
into the sector
as being hate and when it's not hate
it's just barber shop talk at the end of
the day it's been going on for
generations but now
we have a platform for it let's keep it
going
he positions himself as a
high value male right
a top earner over six figures yada yada
yada you know the rest
over six feet over six figures the whole
nine right
so and women have to respect that
they have to they have to feel lucky to
have a man of such stature
okay i don't really like that notion
because a high-value male that has
access to
whatever woman he wants i believe starts
early in life right and [ __ ] it i use
myself as an example
oh i've never had an issue getting
whatever beautiful woman that i wanted
that i just
you see the the the issue with what he's
setting up
and he says something too about you know
if a dude is a
high-value man then uh a woman should
feel happy
really what i think that it is is that
it comes from a layer of
understanding how rare that they are and
then
understanding what are the things that
you are doing to disable
your ability to get one of those dudes
okay
now when he sets up when he proposes
that i don't agree with this and
that it's from when you're born and i
use myself as an example
and mike rashid is genetically gifted so
i think it's not fair to use yourself as
an example
when from like a body composition
perspective
you are in the top 1 of dude so much in
fact
that you have businesses made off of
what
you look like and those businesses
generate
incredible fun but i think all he's
saying is that
like those guys are even like higher
so to speak than the guys that like can
get in the top ten percent like
i think he's just saying like the top
like five percent
maybe or two percent whatever you want
to put it is just born there
which then increases your access to
women but earlier on in life
the funds are perhaps not as important
but still you had
way more genetic gifts than the average
dude so
using yourself as an example is a bad
anecdotal representation
of the average but i think he's saying
that like maybe they can get
like this guy or whoever can get in the
top like 15
20 whatever you want to put it
not but like the top like five it's kind
of like in anything like if you want to
get in the top five
two percent of any even sport any
anything like you have to have some
natural talent
you have to like nobody's getting in the
nba
without some natural talent whether it's
just high like some people have more
than others and some people are able
to outwork others that maybe have more
talent but if you work hard and you have
talent you're gonna
be in a higher percentage of something
of the masses
okay but let's keep going
desired money or not
i feel like a lot of guys are coming
into some success some financial success
and now they're i'm a high value male
yes oh my gosh because you got money
money might not make demand so everybody
out there listening
so i just need to get to the bag you
need to establish
a solid foundation and earn money that's
what we do
we're we're hunters we go out there and
we go get it
we provide we protect but money
in itself is not the end-all and money
in europe
i've seen girls simp over very broke
guys like very broke
so it's not all about money if you're
elaine
money makes you a bigger lane that's
true and i got to say this that's kind
of
true there's a lot of people in the
fitness industry that i i was finding
myself hanging out with being cool with
because we're all making money but i had
to separate myself from them because i'm
like
i don't really like these people you're
only
cool with me because we're on similar
social static
socioeconomic statuses right if this
wasn't a case you probably
call the police on me you probably
wouldn't you know what i'm saying and
a lot of these people they're putting
forth all of their material things
and i'm not against materialism i'm a
materialistic person
it doesn't define me but i like nice
[ __ ] i'm not gonna act like i don't
but you'll never see me just project
like
funny-looking suits and i've definitely
seen that where people like
get accomplished in something and then
they feel like their entire
like they almost talk down to you and
like look down on you
just because like they've accomplished
something
when everyone knows that they're lame
posting my car every
i day and separate myself from people
like that right because that's not that
doesn't create that's not
that's not who i am right it's so much
more so
i had adult life all my life you know
what i mean
money or not so and i've had
access and my pick of some of the most
beautiful women in the world
it is what it is that doesn't come from
money
you know what i'm saying that comes from
just who you are your character how you
were brought up and genetics you know
and i'ma just again as i said like top
five percent top 15 percent
top 20 whatever the cutoff is
like you can't overlook the fact that
like
certain guys get more girls once they
have money you know
i you know i noticed that a lot of these
red pillars
it is what it is they want to talk down
to women whatever whatever
and and they like to throw out the term
symp right
this is the thing but this is the this
is the thing i hate about when they say
sims they basically call a simp anyone
that has a relationship that doesn't
work out where the girl ends it
is what i have noticed like they're
going to say that jeff
bezos was a simp he's cheating on his
wife guys
how is he a simp they act alpha or they
say you're beta you're a symph
not one of these guys would say that
[ __ ] in person
you know what i'm saying i'm not
probably i'm not beta
clearly right so it's interesting though
that people that
be stuck in that [ __ ] saying that so he
says clearly but
again my g it's from a physical
perspective
right and i agree with you and listen at
the end of the day when i first started
this platform
when i first started it you know how
many simps and betas
were thrown my way two years ago when i
first started uploading video
and much of the things that i was saying
two years ago are still the same today
but i think that there's something a
part of male nature that
if you don't understand what it is that
our tribe
is talking about then you are lesser
than us so
we're gonna label you terms
that diminishes who you are and it
happens
it's not just you that [ __ ] again if you
go back and look at my comments
i was getting lit up but i pursued
through that i ignored all the [ __ ]
cut through the noise
and now it's a lot different right now
you know what i'm saying and there's not
a content creator in the space that
doesn't receive
comments like that because the things
that they talk about is a little bit
different than
the content creator that that commenter
normally listens to
they we all experience it you understand
me but i haven't seen
the fresh and fit podcast of you and
were they calling you sim and beta
because of the specific things that you
were saying
and that has to be picked apart as well
right
because they call it that's what i say
people will give me [ __ ] for this but
everyone calls
they call everyone a simp in the mannose
fear
it actually annoys me like they
literally think everyone's just
saying things that was simp like
behavior then that's why
you were labeled that or if you said
things that were rose-colored glass
oh that's interesting that says i.e blue
pill
in nature then that's why it would
elicit that type of response
or maybe not maybe just the way that you
spit your information is different than
what people heard and they just
labeled you x y and z but when you don't
have the opportunity
to be aggressive with someone and of
course the internet dismantles that and
they can hide behind a profile picture
and a fake name then people could just
say whatever they want but let's keep
going
[ __ ] they go to other men's channel
to get advice on how to talk to girls
and how to deal with girls
i don't do that right so it's kind of
weird it's kind of interesting
and a lot of people will subscribe to
certain notions
because it's popular it's the thing to
do everybody else is doing it
everybody's saying red pill red pill red
pill now i [ __ ] with the red pill
philosophy
from the matrix i'm with that
but this whole man women got it easy
we get the short into the stick i don't
i don't feel like that
you know what i'm saying men women easy
i think there's benefits and like
there's
like com ben like benefits and
like downside like on both sides
oh my gosh i can't talk to that i know
everybody's lives are different benefits
and costs so oh my gosh that's what i
was trying to decide right
so i'ma stop it right here uh cause this
video is getting too long so guys i'm
gonna leave a link to this entire live
stream down the description box down
below they went on for about
30 more minutes all right so i'll leave
it down in there feel free to go down in
there and finish off the conversation
yeah i i don't agree with it either i
don't agree that um
men are being oppressed uh but what i do
think though
is that women don't understand how
privileged that they
are yeah that's something i've
definitely realized
since starting like watching these
channels because there were always
people that be people that said to me
like oh it's because you're a girl it's
because you're a girl
um and sometimes i think people overuse
that and that's what annoys me
is when people overuse it but like i've
seen
like just through watching this content
i can understand like more what it's
like to be
a guy so it's actually been helpful not
all not all not all
but the majority but when you have the
images
as they are purported to them when you
have movements such as feminism
right and i think the manosphere i've
said this time and time again the
manosphere is a reaction to feminism
really the only
thing that feminism has to do with the
word femininity is that they
sound the same it really doesn't i mean
the waves today really push these
masculine
behaviors and characteristics and push
this idea of
independence and sexual liberation and
that
no matter where those doesn't understand
in general in mass how much that has
a debilitating effect on their
intellect but not only that but it
lowers the
amount of valuable dudes that will want
them into the future you understand me
so
i think that the whole red pill
discussion this is why i shy away from
that
word on my channel as well because these
are just my thoughts
these are just my ideologies and i try
to create frameworks
on top of that right so maybe at some
point i'll go do
a breakdown of his interview on fresh
and fit just to see what the things that
he was saying just to have a better
understanding
that'd be fun why i'm gonna do that too
okay i think i'm gonna end it there
i really like this content creator i'm
new to him but i definitely agree with
what
like different parts that he was talking
about i think they call everybody beta
in red pill so
it kind of takes away like the
seriousness when i hear that word
because i call everybody it
and i do think that in order to be in
like the top like
five percent or whatever like the dating
pool you have to have some natural
talent and that's what the guy in the
video was talking about
but let me know what you think in the
comments do not forget to subscribe to
the channel get me to 20 000 subscribers
that's the next goal
and i will talk to you guys next time